you know you came all the way from Japan
is there anybody at home or is there
anybody that you want to give a shout
out to yes that's one thing I want to
say hiking game is pumping so great
[Applause]
you know we all come together to
celebrate fighting game and as you said
fighting games are great damn it why did
he say that I know that's what you guys
don't know that's what got James the
workers it almost got me too I won't lie
it wouldn't it wouldn't be evil without
that view would it
[Applause]
[Music]
and there's still plenty of time for the
clockmaker company you put the streak of
all
[Applause]
stammers I don't know what to do and
also the josephus does not up oh the bad
breath
don't wake daddy so what wonder what the
guys I was working out do meters what's
he gonna do what's how I gonna do
that'll go for some hot box the Sun it
water works everywhere no water boiler a
lot is about you need a Christmas
careful here from launches the great for
the second minute the hot shoe
[Music]
okay start of a beautiful relationship
oh yeah a big damage look at that
no you can also you know oh my god
just around everybody's under [ __ ] in
every white audience winner stop right
now
hungrybox a favorite to win this
tournament like what you hear about
we're going to win there's people oh
what'd he say about it
oh good reactionary class mean person at
it laughing laptop hungrybox cobol 11 in
oh my god oh Emily victim of the rodeo
what can I predict he is now at a huge
live advantage here oh boy oh god for
the second ad he could have killed their
homes believable the rodeo I can show
Danny he are being a little bit
flustered here and there Lord life with
AIG does that wait a minute who's
sending Ruth to the rodeo River cowgirl
watch out oh my baby oh my god still
alive I can't believe it you got a
little bit on the range oh he's dead
he's dead oh my god it was done oh not
quite actually excited going to matters
gonna be Jeff oh shoot
why would not devote for such a move at
they're very flexible but probably
thought that he was going to wake up
with a button pain with one pixel one
man military he's got a comeback here
make-ahead poison
oh I throw it on void and what's going
on here oh okay my could have been a
game changer Oh Dody from downtown the
whole range for whole football field
ha ha ha dolphin kick what does they
know AB cross my mind
well they'll put the plans on how are
you doing yours we thirteen all that's
left but one hits gonna do it that's it
that did hit the crowd going nuts one
more agent that's a big more complaint
canary well
all right here the whole example this
one class will clinch the bar if it gets
leaked spigot David and now have so good
one is oh boy and you trouble now how it
has all the resources is afraid to come
over to the flat bar wheels out the
quarterback
oh the hit has a dream at a meter the
screen went away well as great fireball
from California just like this Alucard
is now with the properties interactable
development all right it is wait wait a
minute a I look like a finalized amazing
comeback from Alucard como combo I agree
no paradigm as automated in the world
oh he just going to guess lightening up
for success reading outside gone a go in
the end such a smart one over here from
Dora he finally find a heaven to avoid
the book on a brain what a company they
probably our bottom it even got to be
super clutch years through the blog
waited a bird he's got Peter you can
cancel into the fireball here into the
firm huge damage and is that God there's
all three bars on that combo that's
right early on before Nagi to mash in
some of those drinks puts fear into the
heart of the Raven player this character
has no health very high glutes though
okay now yeah without on the table this
trying to a bar there with two s the
blotchiness if necessary slide to work
out for our
in Slovakia the entire spring Marva
Caulfield book getting away to the bomb
but a great counter hit air-to-air
conversion for nominating max damage off
that opportunity something if you do not
get a lot make them up on the way into
Naga take the corner this is difficult
escape situation for Raven is air Wow oh
you read before - brother
yeah now letting him out of the floor
except some sleeping with the picked
agent he's trying to get down to open
for oh okay oh okay
the person that is good we don't even
need to see a shot of it a three side of
it a brief rain this is over to Peru as
gaining momentum back all right
oh no oh no who is that thing Jack you
got a cue got act he got a backpacker
are you serious I'm sorry I'm sorry if
that was my I don't blame me I'm sorry
the ball around will remain you oh my
goodness
Eli oh good clock oh my god when he got
the Black Friday special but disease
every bit breaks it's not Filipino
champion genetic file from last round
really
target became old to be fair is it he
saw miracle coming out so he got the
battery up a bit it's a coastal son the
throw he's going to get the game off
this Paquito a massive comeback a huge
swing and he stays alive right Dave hi
keep it going let's go with that boat
back off for a connector men why you
more than 150 bucks
there's a little ticket made he found a
well cannot believe it look it is
popular is pouring out of his men right
now that trip up our beautiful we're
about to get such that oh oh the cars
realize what that will be hell yeah have
taken it over wolf chrome Filipino Jim
monthly burning here cares very
well-made angler captain giant air time
but like they got no sense and he makes
it the subpage ladies and gentlemen
prodigy he mainly when it was back to
back honeybees and his birthday Aikido
sit sonic Buster loses and he if the
cake two years later sitting upon
solution and it's all level you throwing
Christmas area with a pop-up for you
for the whole session Wow whoa Wow like
did it yeah old-school - damn this man
whatever loose whoa before once is given
the back raise your hand in victory
however you got the lead so I can't
really get fed how'd you land it yes
how about that one coming into that or
the Oh from deep or force Oh God
yeah ah ha ha ha ha ha yeah I get to
play you know the only the highest to
give the Ireland to gain and himself
throws awful stuff why is this guy here
you say you watch it Oh God uh agree
with me what's to the wall want to look
open up wrong you better believe he's
gonna burn this meter you hold any
jogger if they kill multiple an evil
your Evo champion landing is this is he
evil tribute he's been waiting to play
monsterbowl I'm too old monastic quite
oh it's our fault the Boy Wonder at all
at dark balsa silica while night the
Swedish sniper earning his reputation
that he did about hi
oh no that was your jab come out what a
wall go for it again but this time
actually listen back okay I like this
yep on the back working to do it goes up
all and no all right okay okay oh yeah
oh yeah oh I could you know but I'm
still languages so where's the repeat a
cylinder kids no no right now and I'll
cut oh my god but that was but that's
beautiful greninja playing oh by the
e100 about the soul who oh my goodness
here we go back to Bengston besides that
was so sick oh my goodness oh not like
this only are they fit to bond track one
of the beasts of the PBC one pretty I
know what
oh my god laughs are those little knock
whoa that decision is big house because
I like what he did there
polka Tonto hair metal is on the hood Oh
little fluid way to go boy that's though
in the game doing great and when the guy
catches them with the Haggadah oh holy
moly Gucci you are here to play go
pilgrimage something must be done
this is this
is the ruffle man home oh my god oh my
god Larry
Oh Lord left Larry Lord right there good
lord what how do we just that's going to
be damaged you oh wow
thanks hunter so time kills eight again
put anyone's game anyone can take this
right here you say I have a hundred
Ramirez good artsy mix them up he's
actually down help oh can you open him
up beef Bronx been raised in a society
and then the oh no anus he says painted
like it
an old beautiful fireplace there from
Pepito there he has the opportunity go
either direction they don't going to be
a son very close he hit a [ __ ] he
proceeded so far he's did a dog rowboat
a funk a grand finals of an EVO jab
walks up and get smashed out of me
battle the Americas without the three
framers whoa you know it's all about the
bridge but you probably come off and yet
dr. Oxley what the hell was that
ooh nice
to get a pump off they all kind of brag
motor just cool control and yeah gonna
go to control what is the setup Oh yup
right out to set up oh no my god and
this might be all Ryan
he'll be filling in a burger bareback
said yeah you had to get a like a farm
they're funny way it's a little bit
little bit funny with you but if that
gave everything solving this problem man
he did you head oh my god now it goes to
the orbital to get punished they're nice
with what it's trumpet wow look at this
damage oh my god I just looked up at the
bar and look at the wall here that's
gonna do a ton of damage is that going
to be the pole rock god oh oh and get
started that little that's all you need
for Ben Darras is so hard to score that
but he's getting to knock down hitting
the mess up I did it and already blocks
up the freezer roll out of there you
won't of me oh here already gets done
we're starting off the tournament with a
Ben Jerry's sunny cool I was just
wondering oh there is the beautiful got
man like that man speed to hit and I'm
ending another one
oh are you serious
Louis tempt oh here he goes there's no
flash and you have to deal with all of
this the aides of chance
oh the big there be that hundred ohm is
ridiculous honey bee baby gold a trick
for the end
we actually want to I feel like you know
Lawson is really made people believe in
yeah I love that I love the magnetic
supplement characters ever drop them and
was able to turn them into a hold of the
tournament winner winning character look
at this watch at starting with the
perfect on Justin blog for Street
Fighter pool and they're losing more and
their futile streak beautiful kill the
momentum it massive attack is looking
miserable here for pump target so much
trouble
here is where the mental quality Wow
total is just way over there oh and read
on the first it's going to finish him
off here 40 watt 50% of his health and
go defensive Austin's beautiful you try
to take out but he got hit clean hate no
tell us after all you look pretty the
Super's at the perfect
the plot is going nuts right now the
evil 2015 winners I mean we're broke
here or go already in the corner not
just expected a oh-ho-ho-ho always
something heads out after going to have
to birth doubtless take that was a block
it he's at first anyway just want to
keep it going oh my god well not it it's
so smug it's not a meter at the rock
wall is that it got a solid save for a
15 winner Oh cow
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button